every year during the mid-autumn
festival my family gathers around the
table to indulge in moon cakes moon
cakes are like works of art
one of the most popular types of moon
cakes is the one with the salted egg
yolk in the middle covered with a sweet
lotus paste and encased in a golden
dough then finally molded with the most
intricate and beautiful designs we'd cut
them into quarters and we bet on which
slice would have the most yolk and then
we'd fight for it
they're rich
sweet savory and made with lots of hard
work and love
i even remember as a small girl thinking
that they were too beautiful to eat
one year my mom had given me a moon cake
to bring to school to share with my
friends
i remember thinking that i would eat it
alone during recess because i was too
scared to share my culture
i didn't want to share these traditions
that others would find strange
but as i sneakily took it out of my
backpack my friend turned to me
excitedly and told me it was the
prettiest thing they had ever seen she
wanted to try it
my face lit up and we shared the
mooncake and i began to tell her all
about the legend of chang-uh the chinese
goddess of the moon
[Music]
now maybe you've never seen moon cakes
before maybe you're remembering that the
first time you learned about moon cakes
was when you were sitting in front of
the tv watching wendy wu homecoming
warrior on disney channel
either way you're about to see how to
make these beautiful moon cakes and how
they came to be an iconic part of the
mid-autumn festival from the famous
ancient chinese myth
the legend goes that a chinese archer
named ho e shot down nine sons from the
sky
leaving just one
saving the world from being scorched
and after his courageous act he was
given an elixir of immortality from
heaven
hoi's wife chang uh drank the elixir
which caused her to become so light she
floated all the way to the moon with
nothing but her rabbit companion
some iterations of the story say that
chang a drink the elixir as an attempt
to keep it away from ho e's wicked
apprentice while ho he was out hunting
haui began to prepare a feast each year
on the day when the moon was at its
fullest in honor of his wife who he
missed
hoping to see her shadow on the moon and
this feast included moon cakes
a traditional treat eaten during the
mid-autumn festival even till this day
but not everyone shared moon cakes as a
treat of love and admiration
it was once reported that the treats
became popular during the yuan dynasty
when the cakes were reportedly used as
paywall essentially a vessel to deliver
secret notes to assist han chinese in
overthrowing the mongolian rulers of the
time
the mid-autumn festival is traditionally
celebrated on the 15th day of the eighth
month which is supposedly the night the
moon is at its fullest and brightest
each country celebrates in their own
special ways in vietnam the festival is
considered children's day with
celebrations including paper lantern
fairs and lion dance parades
in southern china many people eat autumn
fruits like pomelos and star fruit as
well as lighting lanterns
certain villages in hong kong keep up
the tradition of fire dragon dancing
throughout narrow alleys in south korea
the festival lasts three days and is
used as a time to sweep ancestors tombs
and wear traditional garb
in japan people eat grilled sticky rice
balls while partaking in moon viewings
and in taiwan people have barbecues and
admire the moon
nowadays you'll see families exchanging
mooncakes of all sorts of flavors the
traditional lotus seed paste with salted
egg yolk red bean
nuts
custard green tea
chocolate and many more families gather
and have a feast with lots of food
fruits and desserts and while everyone
has different ways of celebrating
mid-autumn festival family is always at
the center
the festival is filled with joy and
laughter sharing special traditions
admiring the moon and of course sharing
moon cakes and while some people may
find moon cakes strange or unappetizing
they're always going to be special to me
it was once a food i was too embarrassed
to share because i was ashamed of my
culture
i was ashamed of myself
but not anymore
i love being able to share moon cakes
with my friends and family and telling
them about old chinese legends and the
traditions that come with it i love that
moon cakes remind me to be proud of my
heritage and i love that moon cakes are
little beautiful works of art that you
share with your friends and family you
love so much the most special people in
your life
and i hope you get to enjoy some
mooncakes this year happy mid-autumn
festival
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you